does the antagonists have to be the
strongest character in a movie hmm well
that strongest versus not strongest I
would say they should need to be at
least as well-defined as your hero I
don't know I think they need to be one
of the strongest if not the stronger
like the hero and the antagonists
probably I would say neck-and-neck as
far as well-defined like oftentimes the
antagonist is not well-defined it's just
a villain I've heard it described bad
villains as muahaha villains well it's
just they're just evil for the sake of
being evil that is the most
uninteresting villain you could create
it's the bad guy doing evil haha
laughing as he beats up somebody like
come on
you know that's what's more terrifying
like for example I think this may be a
terrible example but in the force
awakens you've got kylo Ren you know the
son of Han Solo right he's he's
essentially sort of a villain probably
an antihero slash villain he's a
complicated character but to me I found
him really terrifying because he's he's
like a child with a lot of power that to
me is scary he wants to be loved
no one's loved him before that's the
impression I got from him as a character
but he can boy he can stop a bullet and
it really makes you afraid of him
because he's so well developed I think
everyone can identify with that sense of
wanting to be loved I think we've all
been in the presence of someone with a
lot of power and you don't know if
they're gonna snap at you and do
something dangerous like that man that's
way way more interesting than someone
who's just evil for the sake of being
able I mean actually a perfect example
the guy that has his rival in the movie
the Brandon gray jury saw the redhead
guy who places his their same age
blanking on his name Gleason plays you
like he is a little bit more like evil
for the sake of being evil he doesn't
really have the backstory kylo Ren
Hanna's right so there's makes kylo Ren
way more memorable in that film and
you've talked about the back store
in the wound and you compared several
films and said that all of them were
orphans yeah that's an interesting
Batman spider-man Harry Potter James
Bond Luke Skywalker yet the fact that
those are all orphans is not an accident
that that's on purpose that's because
the idea of not having parents is like
we can all identify with it would that
might be like giving your hero wound
that's another way to get them to care
about us to care about them
I mean orphan is one way but like I mean
look at Jason Bourne his wound is
amnesia that makes you really go oh man
that's that sucks you know that's that's
a great you make them great at what they
do and some sort of wound that they're
dealing with is is too powerful
narrative things to do and Matt Damon
and Google hunting you have parents
either
yeah that's right right yeah and you
know his wound is from the foster system
his wound is this mental anguish that he
carries with him so yeah absolutely
makes you want you want him to learn to
love so bad in that movie it's not said
yeah that's it
it's such a brilliantly written film
that's well done character
you